In the past, people used to find tricks
and detours to make Google search engine
think that they should be
ranked at the top of the page.
But the algorithm just
became smarter than us, and
it understands when
people try to do evil.
Tricks like writing your top key words
in white in the background of your page
just don't work anymore, but nice try.
That being said there are still things
that you can do to help your SEO.
Your best choice is to make
sure your website is relevant
to the key words that
you're trying to promote.
If your keyword is pet sitting you
really want to make sure that people
that are searching for pet sitting
will find your website useful and
will want to spend more
time on your website.
That being said, words matter.
The search algorithm searches
every single word on the web,
including every word on your page so
the words you put on the page matter.
However, don't just pack
your site with search terms.
Because the algorithm is going to
be able to tell if they're actually
relevant to your site or not.
And if it's actually useful to
the person doing the searching.
So if it's not, the algorithm is
going to end up working against you.
You're going to want to make sure
that you refresh your content so
it's always up to date and
staying alive.
If you have quality, growing content
on your site and growing links to your
site, the better the search engine
algorithm is going to rate you.
On that note,
what other people say matters.
It's even better when other people say
the great things about your website that
you would like to say yourself.
For example, if on the first page of
TechCrunch they say that Abarkment is
the best pet sitting app, with a link
to our site, that makes us look
really good, because they're
validating that, well, we're awesome.
So this will help our SEO.
However, don't forget that
the algorithm is smart.
If you try to just buy
links to your site.
That aren't actually relevant,
the search engine is going to know.
The more trustworthy your site is,
the higher the algorithm rates you.
The title of your page or
the meta data on your page also matter.
Now, this isn't visible to users,
it's actually hidden in your code base.
But it matters because it's
used as a suggestion for
the title in the Google search results.
This is where you're going to want to
describe your business in an informative
and concise phrase.
This is also true for your domain name.
It needs to be easy to read and
easy to understand.
And finally,
don't leave your images hanging.
People often forget to
optimize their images.
You're going to want to give your images
a short, descriptive file name, and
in the alt attribute,
describe what the image is.
And don't forget to add a caption for
each image.
Your caption should also
contain your keywords.